hello good morning good afternoon good
evening good middle of the night
wherever you are in the world and
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel live and we are talking to
Matthew hello
and Harris hello
how are we all
doing well not bad good good good good
uh we do have a little bit of a topic
today we're going to be talking about
little Stargate I have some statements
I'm going to make that I have
intentionally written to cause an
argument so how that goes but before we
get into that Paris just because I've
been out all day which is why we're a
little late today Harris just dropped on
us actually the Director's Guild of
America have an agreement
to prevent and them going on strike
um we're gonna have a little chat about
that first but this actually does go
into something I was told by one of the
people I speak to actually that in the
next seven days they're expecting The
Writers Guild of America to strike a
deal as well which might mean
no more strike which might mean
all of our hoax for Stargate in the next
few weeks might come to fruition but
anyway here we go
I do have a little bit of Stargate news
but we'll we'll do that in a minute
let's talk about the writer's Guild this
this Director's Guild thing first
yeah I've Just Seen Siri going off and
she's thinking don't say anything I'm
live
you just started talking to her and now
you've prompted no she's thinking I'm
sorry I don't know that
anyway before we get stuck into it shall
I just quickly read through what the
agreement is just very briefly and we'll
just I'll try and summarize it a nice
day big Increase five percent increase
in wages everything there's a big
substantial increases in residuals which
that's the big thing that the writers
have been getting annoyed about
um a huge increase in the um 76 in
foreign residuals a big agreement on the
artificial intelligence that basically
says artificial intelligence is not a
person that really doesn't need surely
to quickly written down like yeah you
don't want to piss the AI off already
come on now yeah there are taking away
their rights already that's that's
probably to prevent creative lawyers
because somewhere out there is an
imaginative well you know kind of like
Riker had to defend data back in the day
you know someone out there
could not replace the duties performance
of members now that's a little bit
different I was just talking to you guys
before so The Writers Guild of America
are kind of annoyed about residuals that
their work gets pumped into these AIS
and the Stargate example is perfect
companion that basically they fed in a
load of scripts from Stargate over the
years fed it into an AI and then the AI
spat out a new script based on that and
the writers are basically saying well
don't I deserve some of the residuals
and that then because that's kind of my
work that's been used to do that
so that's a little bit different with
the writer's Guild but it's still a good
decision
um it goes on a bit feature directors
episode of directors but the main thing
is the writers the Director's Guild of
America making this deal
really does take the carpet from under
the writer's Guild in lots of ways but
guys what do you think
whoever somebody jump in
go shut up Harrison Aaron are going to
be the best ones to talk about this I
think
all right uh proceed sir oh okay all
right well uh I honestly I think it's a
good thing uh I
I I want to join some of these things
someday so so I don't want to poo poo
anything too bad but
I I I I agree with the writers for
striking and doing all these things but
they're they're I don't necessarily
think it was the right time per se uh it
was just a bad timing at the end of the
day and I don't think in that timeline
it made sense for the DGA to continue a
strike and I I don't think the PGA would
strike either sag sag is always willing
to strike so that's that's going to
happen one way or another most likely
but with this news it might not which
could be interesting uh it definitely
throws a wrench in that like long-term
strike that we've all kind of just been
like okay are we gonna have to deal with
Summer are we gonna have to deal with
past summer are we gonna have to go to
the end of the year waiting on this no
like like you just said maybe it could
be the next week uh and this decision is
probably that
that thing that kind of like uh the the
focal point of why that decision might
be made that quickly instead of way down
the line I guess it's good I think
hopefully it allows the industry to keep
moving and obviously we know people Were
Striking for a reason now
let's get the deals going and then let's
get the industry back moving uh it's
nobody wants to not get paid for the
next three months five months six months
eight months yeah come on you know
and do you think this gives us about at
least a blueprint
for then what the studios can take to
the wga
oh yeah for sure the question at least
from The Writer's Guild perspective is
is it somewhat close to what they wanted
or did the directors just you know
hose them in some way shape or form by
it's always the first one to the table
and the first one away from the table
who sets who sets the bar
um works the same way in sports
negotiations too every year someone
someone at some position gets a record
deal and then the next year the next
badass at that position is going to want
that minimum or much more so
um it yeah they from the consumer side
of things hell yeah this is great news
it means you know things are going to be
able to start moving on the stuff we've
been hearing about and like looking
forward to for a hot minute now Stargate
um good Marvel
um
you know that kind of thing so yeah for
for the strike ending more quickly
that's beautiful for us on this side
for the writers I I can't imagine right
now I can only imagine the emails and
texts that are flying back and forth
between these two guilds right now
because there's no way the writers are
not
pissed beyond recognition at this point
they have to be absolutely livid because
I'm pretty sure they were constant they
were not concentrating Counting on like
a full measure of solidarity to help
them get what they wanted
well that's gone now I mean sad could
still stand with him because said can
shut Hollywood down just like that no
actors you have nothing
so
but I I don't mean to interject or
anything I like the analogy a lot by the
way uh but uh I
like if the DJ like you just said is not
standing on solidarity sag may or may
not so that that could definitely put a
hamper on things in these states but if
the DGA isn't standing in solidarity why
would Canada stand in solidarity with
with everybody here why would the UK or
the European stand in solidarity if we
as Americans aren't standing in
solidarity with each other in in this
and it makes sense it's different people
different jobs different there's a lot
of differences that go into it so
it does make sense to not be in
solidarity obviously you kind of want
people to be on the same Mind Trap
mindset and and track but
um it's the age-old problem with unions
other than so other than like in the 80s
with the UAW did is pricing themselves
out of existence
it's
how long how much power does solidarity
have into where the pocketbook starts
getting hurt when as soon as that battle
starts that's when things start getting
really hairy so
the one thing is is this too late a deal
now because of this has been announced
through the last 24 hours to actually
affect
the Actors Guild the go that they
basically vote to strike or not tonight
if the actors stand
with the writer's Guild
and then remember it's actually if the
actors strike or not really it's kind of
irrelevant because everything has pretty
much been shut down anyway
um in Hollywood so well things coming up
can still be effective sdcc can still be
affected if I mean there are some people
who can take the stage and handle it all
by themselves but a lot of these
companies like to bring out you know
faces that's going to make everyone go
you know so I mean if the sack strikes
they won't have that option
hmm I love that I love that I love that
thing you do
that's beautiful it's beautiful right
okay well that's interesting let's hope
that this is the beginning of the end as
I said a person that I spoke to that
works in and around this has told me
that look for the next seven days the
next seven days the righteous Guild he
thinks there's a deal right around the
corner I don't know if he knows about
this because I haven't text him back so
I'm going to text him back in a minute
we'll see if he got the audience so um
we'll see if he texts me during the show
and gives me a bit more info but he's
if this ends then oh man I mean I think
we could even get it we could hope to
even get an announcement on Stargate
before San Diego Comic-Con but I think
Senate conference I think they're going
to do a big splash at San Diego so right
um let's do yeah I'm excited I have a uh
I do have to point out someone in the
comments popcorn power said I can't wait
until Bad Robot starts producing new
Stargate episodes I grimaced when I read
that comment
about react on my microphone are you
joking okay
if you watch this video back halfway
through when Aaron and Harry to speak
and I just go
[Laughter]
I was yeah I feel like that is I feel
like that's pessimistic sarcasm and I
own and I'm pretty sure about that
because I live there too so
it's my second language well how about
Bob right underneath that I love that
comment
right underneath popcorn power just
because I love that movie well I think
right now second of two minutes with
North Korea yeah
that was pretty good um popcorn was
joking thank you we don't have to block
them thank you popcorn
[Laughter]
who is this guy
where are the moderators
I am a moderator actually I'm not even
watching it one second let me let me
pump the viewing numbers up quick
quickest sidebar ever real quick last
night when I was on air in a stream for
the I've been with y'all like a year
like over a year streaming like this wow
oh yeah I I I just figured out last
night that that the comments can be seen
in stream yard and I don't have to have
YouTube opened up on like a side window
so I can type up at the same time just
figured that out took a little bit
thank you thank you you invited you to
that you didn't figure out oh I didn't
figure out a damn thing
I was turned around and shoved into like
okay this is where we gotta go
surprise
we've got a little bit of ish star
gating news we'll do that with quickly
and then we'll get on to this week's
topic but here we go
foreign
[Music]
but anyways right so
um in the last week I did a video last
week talking about how MGM looked like
they're starting to get together of sort
of a creative I called it like a
management team but that's because
mostly I didn't really know how to
describe it but a team at NGM that would
be working start working toward the
creative side
um we're very aware of one friend of the
channel that's had a meeting this week
that turned out to be not really so much
to do with this what we thought it might
be but I'm aware of two other people
that have and I've managed to be able to
speak to one of them that did have a
meeting with MGM this week the way they
described it to me they sort of said
it was like I was at a job interview but
I don't know what the job is
um it was one of my other sources that
sort of
um put him forwards for this meeting so
so he was asked about Stargate and other
MGM projects
um for about five ten minutes of this
um interview he has worked this fellow
has worked on other big sci-fi projects
in the past so they were talking about
that a lot and other things he'd done
and the sort of things he would do but
one of the things he was asked when he
was talking about Stargate and was that
you know like Amazon now own this we're
gonna we really want to push forwards
with a few of these big franchises if
you were to bring back something like
this you know how do you think it would
work they talked very briefly apparently
about a hard reboot and look thankfully
this guy said my opinion on hard reboot
is that why bother
um you're just gonna annoy everybody
before you even start
and another other than the Battlestar
Galactic has never worked so hopefully
they were listening and
um
yeah I know
um but it's just interesting that this
conversation was happening but I think
almost in an interesting though almost
more interesting is what sort of they
didn't talk about because again they
were not willing to put any of this
forwards they they didn't show the cards
you know this MGM meeting
um you know they they briefly talked
about this they talked about other
things as well they talked about RoboCop
a little bit they talk about some other
things it was more of like a direction
of MGM
but the guy said all the way through he
felt like this chap wanted to say
something that he couldn't he said like
two or three times he'd start to say
something then he'd stop himself and
catch himself and like we'll start
talking about something else instead she
says it was one of the strangest
meetings
he's ever had and like I said the best
way of saying is it's a job interview
but he has no clue what the job in job
is so already there it's still MGM
really sorry I caught the sun on my back
so edgy
um it's warm here at the moment it's
lovely you you Californians are used to
it but we're not used to it it's been
like 25 degrees the last two days we're
like where's the rain it's so strange
huh
um but yeah don't wish it don't wish it
I keep forgetting to water my plants I
don't mind a little bit but anyway so
that's that's where I like say it's not
really big news it's nothing but it's
again a little bit of an insight into
what's going on and just more
dithering as far as I'm concerned but
hopefully when the writer's Guild and
all this is sorted out they can start
being a little bit more open so we'll
see what happens be great
[Music]
right so I know you started to say
something there but I I just said that'd
be great
the fingers crossed right so we're sort
of comparing Stargate Universe Stargate
Atlantis and Stargate sg1 a little bit
today so I've thought of some discussion
points some little comments guys get
into the comments as well and and play
along
um these are not representing any of my
opinions all right I am I have
specifically sort of talked about this
to hopefully get you guys
um I'm talking and and maybe even angry
so I'm gonna rile us up I'm gonna rile
you up first of all
um
I forgot the name of it oh it's Futurama
really the best sci-fi show ever made
well a thousands
no it wasn't no it wasn't that wasn't
sure there's a reason it gets brought
back over and over and over
canceled but man that's never we're
never living in Mexico the reason a kid
keeps getting brought back is because
legalization is expanding
yeah
popcorn's on fire tonight
will know sidetrack's a huge fan of Alex
gertzman I actually done popcorn point
with the sarcasm today like well done
yeah I get blamed sometimes for sharing
news that I'm told and I get that like
it's my opinion I don't give a crap
about Alex gerstman
um I I don't like what he did with the
first two seasons of Discovery when he
was actually in control
um but I really like Picard season three
even though I've got a video coming out
tomorrow pretty much saying that I don't
like it
anyway
um but as a you know Star Trek
I've been hit and miss but I don't
personally hate my expertsman just that
unfortunately there's a load of people
that work a Paramount the Duke but
that's not my fault but anyway
um
right so this statement Stargate
Atlantis was a carbon copy of star gang
sg1
discuss
nope that wasn't it wasn't
I I I I I can I can
um
I can agree
that the formula of how the episodes are
laid out
very much sg1 but it was a completely
different story and the characters and
the way they interacted
were way different to sg1 it was kind of
the same but it was just I just feel it
was
I don't know I don't know what the word
is it was a little bit more
let less military in a way
okay
because
they're not um they're not in a military
compound they're in Atlantis so they
kind of they can do their own kind of
thing it's the first time the ioa has
had the control that they've had to that
degree yeah they're reporting to a
civilian rather than reporting to a a
general so they have a little bit more
freedom and it feels it's just a little
bit less military but it's in a good way
in a good way
yeah but remind me to come back to the
characters I don't want to oh no let's
talk about the characters a little bit
before we give these guys I think right
so
Ronin was basically tealc
O'Neill was was Shepard and Shepard
Daniel didn't well I could say that
Daniel didn't really have a thing but
Sam was Rodney anyway
um Daniel counterpart the uh because he
was the she knew the locals and she knew
the thing so yeah
we was
um sort of I I would argue that there's
an on off will they won't they between
um between Shepherd and Weir
that was very similar to Daniel uh sorry
O'Neill and Sam
yeah in some ways
um they were Shepard and Taylor yeah
that's what I was like yeah
but Shepherd and we were very much um
was was I think very different to to to
Jack he had somewhat of his sense of
humor but he was more like well Rodney
called him Kirk because he was very
flirtatious whereas Jack would never
have done anything like that no no it
was his own character but I'm saying I
think the core of the character of what
he how his position in the team
was the same as O'Neill he was very much
the lead he was very much the comic
relief in lots of ways he was sarcastic
um
but but yeah he went his own way a
little bit but O'Neill could be a flirt
O'Neill got a couple of ladies over the
time
um so
Daniel was the player in sg1 right
Daniel really was the player
he's better than Indiana Jones in that
sense Indiana Jones only had three
O'Neill had his moments unfortunately
one of the better ones he kept getting
older so
um
so you said uh Jack was the comic relief
for sg1 I agree with that but I I would
say the comic relief for Atlantis was
McKay he was the smart one but he was
very much the comment Kane was more that
Captain okay was almost like Sam but
what Sam became
in like about season four or five
because Sam's character she did get
funny she did she was she bounced off
tea look a lot more but it's different
because they're both almost a straight
man tilk and Sam are both like the
straight men and they're not like
they're definitely not Rodney in that
sense where Roddy's not the straight man
he's he is the comic relief we're both I
feel like Sam's almost she becomes more
teal-like where she's like okay I
understand you not understand exactly
what I'm saying but I'ma find a way to
get my point across and usually I'm
gonna use a little sarcasm because
that's what Jack understands and
responds to
mm-hmm I would just say that they
um the relationship between Rodney and
Shepard was just a little bit more
they were more like brothers they
irritated each other more so it's almost
like they learned from Daniel and
O'Neill and they just made it a bit more
but it's core it was the same
um yeah and then they play with the
characters though don't they I mean Brad
Wright was talking about this and
Twitter a few weeks ago they said but I
basically when he's talking about the
relationships and the salmon in
relationships what the writers they they
get them going but then the actors sort
of lead the way and when you yeah are
getting changes and you react to things
and I just think that's what so they
evolved
but the core of it at the beginning was
let's just do Daniel and O'Neill but
it's now Rodney and Shepard
you know it's like it's the same but
anyway Harris what did you think of the
statement in general before we go around
uh I I generally I agree with it like
just in like the archetype kind of sense
uh but realistically I I I love sg1
obviously I love sg1 but literally what
they did in 10 seasons SGA accomplished
in five and I I would say that SGA is
kind of sg1 2.0 uh it is it is not
necessarily the better show because we
have more time to spend with our sg1
characters and we love them and they're
they're all fantastic and there's a
reason SGA is that good is because
sg1 had to walk so SGA can run and then
SGU can fly but SGU the flying's a
little iffy sometimes we'll see well we
can discuss uh a little later but but I
think SGA is is
the
not not perfect version of sg1 but it's
it's the honed craft version of it I
guess uh it's it's more meticulously
crafted because they've had time to
think about these things uh they weren't
going in with it and saying all right we
got three or four seasons and we have a
general idea where we want to be later
but we gotta work up to this and SGA was
able to just hit that ground going and
it's more of an exploration show uh and
even sg1 is because sg1 goes back and
forth between exploring medical doctor
stuff politics stuff some some lawyer
stuff every now and then I mean it goes
back and forth between a couple
different things and SGA does too and
SGU does too but not to that degree and
I think they allow more time to focus on
uh the story and I I guess they have
just as many arcs as Stargate has like
you know two or three episodes kind of
combined and that like you want to watch
these together kind of deal
and it feels more fluid of a show
because it has as many arcs as sg1 had
but in half the time I guess if that
makes sense
okay Aaron see you then
uh I would there's definitely parallels
in their obvious parallels but I would
not say carbon copy
um there's just enough difference in the
way they treat the characters and even
the story itself
um and the settings they chose to use
um like you know Atlantis was for the
most at least at the beginning obviously
stuck on that one planet with The Wraith
they had to figure out how to get there
they made Harris fall in love with
puddle jumpers
um
right yeah so carbon copy no
I would yeah I go with her kind of a
upgraded isn't quite the right word but
smoothed out version of sd1 probably is
yeah I would say that's probably the
best way to put it not a copy
kind of just like a streamlined SG-1
where like they like Harris said they
already knew what the hell they were
doing by the time they even started
Atlantis so you know all the bums in the
road we got in like the first
three seasons of SG-1 they you know they
could skip all that they already knew
how to avoid that kind of stuff so
yeah not a carbon copy
I feel like the storyline in Atlantis
progressed a lot quicker than unless you
want obviously it did because we had
only had five seasons rather than ten
but especially with The Wraith because
we very quickly got the whole storyline
of can we turn a wraith into a human
with with Michael
and then that the whole
um
debate of is it actually like ethically
yeah ethical right kind of thing and
that was that was a theme that pretty
you know played out towards it right
through to the end of the end of the
series but it was it was very
quick to get there I don't think they
they necessarily had to do the massive
build up that they did with SG-1
in Atlantis and that whole thing that is
we're talking about the Atlantis was
sort of like an evolution of Stargate in
some ways the best you want was Atlantis
I'd argue the same thing for the race
really they they took the idea of
um sort of the
um the the gold how the goal will take
your body they take over you the rate
feed off you but it's you know it's
almost like a Next Step but the thing is
they all took the whole thing was like
the genocide of the gold world was never
really discussed
but it's an obvious Next Step that they
then took with the race
so again that's that thing of like they
just took that next step in lots of ways
with Stargate Atlantis
exactly why I think they they might the
the go award could potentially come back
in the future because they never commit
genocide they just they just killed
their system Lords that's another debate
for another time but that's something
that I didn't think Could Happen of a
space vampires the race out of space
vampires see I prefer The Wraith over
the gold honestly I I I I just think
they make yeah they're more that villain
of the week can't be Villain at times
but
I mean they're they're tough bastards
honestly you know and and there's a lot
of them and there's a lot of things that
they do and then they just the strictly
numbers and and I like that the Gould
have like the Jafar that okay we can't
really do that much without the Jafar
but the wraiths are legitimately a a
terrifying presence on their own uh were
the gold or terrifying on their own but
you take out those system Lords and
they're like in disarray whether they
were genocided or not they're in
disarray and The Wraith
hey I mean yeah they got infighting and
different factions within themselves but
they're still
kind of like okay if you have to we're
teaming up against these guys and that's
usually Atlantis or whoever it is the
race I really like what happens if
Dracula bites Michael Myers
you take away all of their power all of
their followers and all they are is is
people with really deep voices with The
Wraith the thing that makes them scarier
is that they they do what they do
because that's how they survive they're
not they're not doing it because they're
inherently evil that's how they were
created that's how they survive that's
what makes them I think a much scarier
villain than the Gould I mean yeah
because
like they may that they may be a time
when they want to stop but biologically
they can't physical physiological they
can't stop it's part of them they have
to do it in all otherwise they commit
mass suicide
at the end of this is where they've
evolved they're an animal yeah
biggest thing I thought that like
obviously the race are semi-gold like
you know because they they enslave some
people I mean look what they did uh
ronan's character and his people and
stuff but the biggest difference at
least for me is the gold can appear
human and sneak up on you which you
would think could make them a bit
scarier but like just how obviously not
human just humanoid the right they're
just in your face scary they're just
like right there
and it's just like oh
yeah I I kind of like the fact that
they're like
more obvious villains I guess
um and you know I just like the way they
were set up like in hives instead of
like you know they were there like
Harris said they're their own Army like
you'd Mess With The Wraith you're not
messing with
slave Warriors like the trafal where
you're just messing with The Wraith well
it's like the ghoul they're they are
very tough themselves and they're like
powerful whenever they do and inhabit a
host and stuff but ninety percent of
what they rely on are yes other people's
numbers but technology more so like
their own power comes from technology
and The Wraith
yes they're just as technologically
advanced or very close
but they don't need that technology to
really mess up your day you know that's
uh actually the last thing they have to
rely on yeah
because they could just keep walking
forward
giving people high fives yeah
[Laughter]
um
is it fair to say
that sg1 and SGA but are basically when
they made SGA they had a formula from
sg1 and they kept that formula they then
threw that formula out and made Stargate
Universe no
yes until they threw the formula out for
Stargate Universe because Stargate
Universe has the formula still in it
it's just a very different aesthetic in
tone
is the formula comes right back in the
second you're going back to Earth in SGU
with the stones it leads it away from
being that like where we kind of get
closer to that Adventure kind of series
with SGA which is I probably prefer SGA
out of all of them just because and I
wouldn't if sg1 was an sg1 obviously uh
and that's why SGA is as good as it is
but SGU I think continues that with
the the lawyer stuff going back and
holding Court sometimes because you're
on a realistically yeah you have the
citizens versus the military and and it
makes sense like
there's going to be some divisiveness
but the the military would have taken
over a lot quicker if I guess those
stones hadn't been involved and that
keeps SGC kind of uh
in in charge to a degree and as long as
SEC is there I think that formula is
still there uh
if that makes sense does anyone want to
explain to Housewives wrong
no no I I kind of agree I think the
formula
is present in every single one of them
because the formula is
something happens we go through the gate
shenanigans that that's the same that
happens in sg1 so something happens what
happened in the first episode up office
comes through kidnaps other people we
have to go through the game rescue them
and then Shenanigans happen which mean
we have to continue going through the
game
in Atlantis why did we go through the
gate we're in Atlantis but we don't we
don't have any suppliers we're about to
die let's go through the game
Shenanigans happen the race come about
they have to continue going for the Rave
going through the gate in SGU
pretty much the same as with Atlantis
they get on the ship they realize
they've got no supplies they need to go
through the gate Shenanigans happen and
have to continue going through the gate
it's exactly the same no matter what it
is it's just a different mechanism as to
why they're going through the gate in
each in each series the writing formula
is the same or very very similar the
writing the acting and the direction
particularly the direction is what makes
the show feel so different
if that makes sense
okay yeah don't you think huh
um honestly I haven't put eyeballs on
SGU in a very long time but what I do
remember is
uh it definitely has a different feel
for sure
um the aesthetic is completely different
just like the inside of the destiny is
just kind of dimly lit
kind of got that weird kind of yellow
brown background that just evokes
you know just everything seems a lot
more intense in the Aesthetics and in
the way the characters were written
um of course you stick a bunch of people
on a ship billions of light years away
from home they're going to get a little
testy so
um
but yeah um the base form the formula in
its most basic at its most basic level
is still there because
it has to be at least tis even just to a
some small degree in order to keep the
feeling there for everyone to be like
okay yeah that's still starting we still
got started cycling now you need to have
Stargate in it or do you yeah yeah well
you know I can go on forever about how
people like to put Star Wars on content
in any Star Wars so
um
I yeah like they kept the formula at its
most basic level and just kind of
tweaked it when it came to the
Aesthetics and a couple other things but
I would say it's still the same basic
formula so I I agree with this I'm not
basic thing I like hearing as you say
something happens go through Stargate
Shenanigans but and it's I mean but I
would argue that's it that's basic I
would say the formula is there's a lot
more to it there's things like the sg1
team where they act like a family Daniel
tielke and
um O'Neill really act like brothers
bickering half the time and and that
formula translated to Atlantis it didn't
go to Universe at all it couldn't
because in sg1 and Atlantis each
character had somewhere they could go
and they could they could they could
they could basically not be a part of
the program they could do whatever they
wanted they could be just normal people
but in a land in Universe they were
literally trapped they were stuck with
each other 24 7. it's like if me if all
of us in this room in this chat now if
we were stuck in a room well like we get
together once once a week we do this and
we love it but if we were together every
single day 24 7 for as long as they were
we'd hate each other and we we would
fight within a week I'd be trying to
decide which one of you I was going to
kill and eat
uh we've been watching a Futurama reruns
every day be great okay
but we're talking about um Aaron the
overall tone of each show as well you're
gonna fight back it says east coast
right there good luck
talk about the overall like feel of the
each show as well um someone mentioned
SGU was a lot darker and there's a lot
of brown and dark in the background
that's very true
um I think sg1
was kind of like that as well not dark
but everything was kind of
concrete gray walls or and then a forest
Atlantis then came along and it was
everything was very bright and very big
the gate room much bigger yeah
everything was very bright and it felt a
little bit more positive a little bit
more happy even though the stakes were
much higher in Atlanta I think
and then obviously SGU is it was the
complete other end so
Atlantis is once one side then you've
got SG SG-1 kind of in the middle I
would say and then that universe is like
right of the dark end of the spectrum
everything is dark because they're in a
dark situation
Hollywood likes to do that a lot with
anything that lasts a while you know
it's like if they want to build a
franchise off something they'll be like
okay this is popular
let's see let's see what happens if we
tweak it in this direction poof SGA okay
this shit's popular too yeah all right
let's go the opposite way with it now
and see how people react SGU
it's everyone watching I feel like they
do that a lot like
Star Wars basically
the original trilogy except for they did
the dark first instead of the brighter
stuff first but A New Hope was at a
certain level Empire went way darker and
then returned the Jedi got you know
more positive even Than A New Hope did
by the by the time it was all said and
done so Hollywood likes to screw around
like that with franchises it's just the
way they roll that's our creative
talking years ago and he took my CSI and
he said CSI Vegas was obviously very
popular it had a certain neon color base
and they say the color tone of it was
very specific but they said that when
they did CSI Miami because really
sending everything so it says everything
like orange tint to it and says that's
very much done on purpose so everything
was lit and done a certain way it had
orange and sunny and warm but then they
did CSA New York and everything had a
blue tint to it so that's important very
specifically to try to
add that layer of
at that layer of the to absorb you in a
little bit more so you wouldn't
necessarily be even be aware of but
yeah just it's that separation is it you
can't do the same thing right so the
next statement is and I'm talking about
Stargate Universe was yeah Stargate
Universe was just Stargate
Battlestar Galactica Style
Ronald D Moore's Battlestar Galactica
specifically I can't comment because
I've literally only watched one episode
have you seen the mini series of
Battlestar
I'm just watching the season one episode
one and then just no no you go back and
watch the
um the mini-series first honestly it's
it's some of the best sci-fi ever made
at the moment so I'll put it on hold and
I'll go watch that okay and you've got
to watch it anyway that's how the
invasion and everything happens so
you've got to watch that and the mini
series honestly two hours
yeah
in the in the first episode that you saw
do you see the big tall blonde chick
killer baby
you'd notice she killed a baby I don't I
don't know I fell asleep
I was watching it and then I fell asleep
so I only watched half of it but it's in
the first time she's there going oh no
no no and then you just you hear the
baby crying why are they just goes
and the baby stopped crying that didn't
happen
watch the mini series first it's
phenomenal honestly best I think but um
there's definitely a style about Star
Galactica I think it's fair to say
star get SGU copied it
quite
like a lot
have you guys seen Battle Star do you
know what I'm talking about
I haven't seen it these clips I agree
I've seen Clips I've seen I've seen the
Aesthetics and I kind of agree that it
did kind of
a lot want to to go that way with the
shaky cameras and all that kind of [__]
like
but why is that an issue
like imitation is like this in serious
form of flattery it was something that
was popular at the time like why not
give it a go I mean just look at any
Tarantino movie not a single shot in any
of them is an original shot and they're
all excellent because he pays homage to
the great filmmakers and bad filmmakers
that he chooses good things from those
pieces and he obviously likes to watch
bad movies just as much as good movies
and I I feel like that's similar there
yeah yeah see
I was
people have this argument they look it
looked and felt like that's like
Galactica the Sci-Fi copies from each
other all the time like we never have an
issue when they bring in time travel
we're never an issue when they bring in
like replicators because they've been
done to death and everything science
fiction like character the actual like
story lines
which are copies from other sci-fi's is
a much bigger deal I think than just the
the look of of a show yet no one has an
issue with that
and the story still feels Stargate
obviously I haven't seen Battle Star so
I don't know if the story is all that
there but like just just the pictures I
have in mind of like Katie Sackhoff and
uh uh uh
Edward James Olmos just from Battlestar
like those Aesthetics kind of fit SGU
but
I don't know I haven't seen Silent
Running either if you look at if you
watch the Silent Running movie and then
watch Stargate Universe
to anyone
[Laughter]
why
um but I think that's actually a quite a
fair comment because the silent run is
basically move this guy is basically
trapped on the Starship on his own and
he's only got a robot to talk to and he
just slips slowly into madness
um which is always fun
um but actually yeah the tone the
realism
um
I think this is why you know I'm doing a
video this week about my top five most
realistic Sci-Fi movies and Silent
Runnings might be top
possibly but um but yeah Aaron what do
you think
have you seen Battle Star first no I
haven't the closest I've come to watch
even as far as seeing a picture of Katie
sack off at Starbucks and going okay
how does it feel to be me
I'm on Sci-fi channel talking about one
of the most popular sci-fi shows in the
last 20 years and I'm the odd one out
yeah
this time yeah sorry
I'm sorry
I'm an idiot
shut up Jay but now I got it
oh how the turntables I can't even block
him out because you can just
uh
I'm definitely gonna have to look up
that yeah from YouTube would you say
miniseries it literally tells me when
you do that
okay so so just the the brotherly
comment about SGU real quick
I actually don't feel like I feel like
sgu's still brotherly like with Eli and
and Matt
and and and uh maybe even like Ronald or
whatever but obviously Ronald's not as
much uh it but like Matt was saying if
you're stuck on a ship like that for 24
7 we get to see some of the episodes
where they're not as friendly with each
other but if they weren't stuck on the
ship if they had time to go off I feel
like they would have the exact same
brotherly moments that SGA and sg1 had
um
I I just obviously you're not gonna be a
hundred percent happy with each other 24
7 on a ship uh
free time every action taken on SGU
would have been taken by any anyone from
sg1 and SGA if it was
so Russia is like the anti-hero the the
villain ish kind of character in SGU
yeah replace him with McKay he would do
exactly the same thing that Rush does
exactly not worse honestly if not worse
yeah
because they're both arrogant scientists
they think they're right but they don't
get the space to like just just get on
with it they've got someone breathing
down their neck constantly and they've
and arguably Russia's more reasonable
than McKay I mean McKay is kind of
forced into reason a lot of time but he
will straight up just say like f off
zelenko you might be like we're talking
about his uncle later who might be one
of the smartest characters in all
Stargate and
McKay's just like huh get out of here I
don't need you get get the F out of here
I don't like literally if it was a TV
mature show he would be saying F off to
zelinka or anybody 90 of the time where
Russia's kind of like they changed that
the formula so dramatically because yeah
okay they had a character that was
similar in lots of ways but Rush
was cruel
and I don't think the K ever was because
they changed the tone
so dramatically
in Russia's situation put McKay 24 7 on
a ship in space and everybody around him
is not as competent as him and he has to
I mean he's already even whenever things
are just going like typically in SGA
okay you have to con I'm gonna help you
I'm gonna fix everything I'm Dr Rodney
McKay but you have to convince me to
help you fix it first you you have to
force my hand you have to make build me
up to do this he's twice of an [__]
as I think Rush is and I love Ronnie
McKay I love Ryan at risk I mean rush
for people at risk but so did McKay
McKay would in that situation but the
reason
is because of the whole situation they
were in this is this what I think it is
put someone in a tough situation You're
Gonna Go
to either to one side you're it's like a
fight or flight kind of situation
and it's like a switch in your head how
are you going to act those characters
right rush because we've seen it happen
went straight for logic and reason
everything had to be calculated and it
said that's how he made his decisions
and I think that's how McKay would have
probably done it as well that's why he
come across as Catalyst that's why I
come across as not caring it wasn't
anything to do with that he was just
using logic and reason to come to the
conclusions that he did
and it came across like he was an
[__] but really is not he's just
using his intelligence or trying the
best he can he did grow as a character
as things went on it's just that
the way the show was toned there wasn't
that comic relief there to stop us
disliking with Rodney there was always
that comic relief so it stopped just
hating him you know when he's gone away
when he's wearing his shield and things
like that that made us like him with
Rush that they didn't bother with that
part of the formula
so he didn't like Rush some people did
but I feel like I love her at the moment
we we kind of
changed our minds a little bit on rushes
is when Rush kind of came back into
being himself again was when I can't
remember her name the disabled
scientist uh Amy whatever yeah she she
went into the body
he fell in love blah blah blah and he
became
probably what rush would have been had
he had
that around him the entire time he had a
bit of hope I guess
for the Humanities and then he kind of
lost it again towards the end because
obviously she died
spoilers
don't worry I just watched that episode
but but I mean like
I don't know rush I feel like was
humanized both with that and by Colonel
young beating the hell out of him uh it
was like okay because realistically I've
not liked young at all there are moments
where I'm like okay I understand this
but like
I screw that military thought process
like Russia's the only person on that
ship that can like even begin to under
like literally they make it a point
where after he like okay I've broken the
master code this is this and this like
and volcker and Brody and all these
other smart people Dr Parker all in the
room with them he's still having to go
even with Eli he's having to go
all right let's fix this and just goes
around him and kind of and you see
they're kind of like disgruntled faces
but they're they they know this guy's
Leaps and Bounds smarter than us and and
he's he's got to lower himself to our
level there's no way for us to rise to
his and and that would Jade you a little
bit like
as as much as I think Rodney would be
the the more vicious out of the two if
he was put in that scenario
I don't think Samantha Carter would be
all that different either she would
definitely show more compassion just
because who she is and the things she's
been through but realistically she's
gonna apply logic more so than
everything
uh and if if she was there
she'd be military and logic and science
should be she she'd be the dictator of
the ship Amanda Perry that's her name
Amanda Perry I think we saw times with
um Sam though where she would sacrifice
herself before she sacrificed others
whereas it always felt like Rush
was more than willing to sacrifice
everybody for the
um not even to solve a problem Samantha
was all about solving problems he just
wanted to find out
you know and and to get to the the he
just wanted to learn he wanted to learn
more about Destiny he wanted to learn
what it was like for science that he was
his Focus whereas Sam I think was a
problem solver yeah but like I say Rush
was more than willing to sacrifice
everybody on that mission
I don't even know if he's so much a
antagonist or even an anti-hero he's
more along the he's just um oh damn it I
had the word
uh number one he's kind of Machiavellian
you know it's just he does it doesn't
matter to him what he has to do to get
to a certain point
um he's he's just gonna do it and you
know Heaven help you if you're in his
way
um
what is the other word I was thinking of
it start with an a crap
if I suddenly just come out if I
suddenly just yell it out I'm you know
just think oh he was still talking about
Rush right there but I can't remember
you know amoral he's very amoral he's
not he's not necessarily evil he's not
necessarily an antagonist or a villain
he's just a moral and very Machiavellian
yeah yeah
that makes sense cool
right we're pushing on an hour and we
haven't we're still only halfway through
so we gotta come with this we've done
two
we got a couple of the easy ones though
teal could kick ronan's ass
he's older he's way older he's got more
experience of course he will
but Ronan literally had to survive years
of running away from The Wraith I think
Ronan wins just from attrition I think
tilk is the better fighter but I think
Ronan would win strictly from attrition
I don't know I think it takes a certain
in a in a power as well as out of power
and to you know serve a god you that
literally you absolutely hate
but that's that was also just the status
quo for like literally Millennia at that
point it wasn't like out of the ordinary
I mean the the bigger thing for tielke
was literally doing the opposite of that
like that was the harder thing for him
to ever do was just because he had a
great position he was like okay I can
provide for my family I can do this I'm
literally the second up to a god like I
I can do what I feel like and the harder
decision was him having to literally say
I'm throwing all that for the chance of
throwing that at all away for a chance
of Freedom you know and freedom for my
people where ronan's like
I'd have to survive I have literally
space vampires that are like Darth Vader
space vampires coming after me I don't
know what to do I just shoot and run and
I think purely good attrition maybe it'd
be a great fight though deadly Warrior
that [__] let's do it
I mean they did kind of do it didn't
they in in Atlantis and we never really
got a proper conclusion I do think tilt
would probably win though
I do think till overall would win all
right let's get let's really nerd it are
we talking Prime teal versus Prime Ronin
or like as they I think 150 year old
kill could be Ronan huh 150 year old
root tilk like where he is now he could
still be running the White Street yeah
put it this way that's why the way I see
this
honestly I think it comes down to like
weaponry and Terrain
I think it literally they're probably I
think three P90s he's just like as
Warriors I think they're basically on
equal footing in terms of knowledge and
like raw athleticism and strength and
ability because they're both both of
them are stronger than you know a normal
human it's like they're they're so they
have that in common they're both highly
weapons proficient
uh both
very uh martial arts type proficient you
know hand-to-hand combat quite
proficient they're basic yeah it it I
think honestly it just come down to who
messed up first
yeah there is a I think there is a
distinct point in teok's life where he
probably
would start to struggle as opposed to
younger self and that was the moment he
removed his symbiote and started going
onto tonan when he asked his symbiote I
reckon he's probably probably Stronger
Yeah but trotonin
pretty much does the same thing it just
gives his immune system back I don't
think it gives him the strength
as far as I know that a little bit
didn't he in certain episodes that he
said that he was not quite the the
warrior he was before yeah still skilled
just yeah it doesn't have that raw power
that he had yeah see I I still think he
would win
but I'm going to change my answer not
150 year old till tilk the day before he
removed his symbiote
SG-1 teal compared to a sg1 first season
teal compared to Ronan firstly I'm
saying that
prime prime is going to win that
because I've got my face and I use my
mouth too often I've been in a few
fights over the years and I'm five foot
seven and I think I'm six foot three and
so I'm saying that are you the guy that
goes you want some you won champ you got
no fans
[Laughter]
talking about
um so
um I I think this this fight would come
down to one moment of luck either way
because neither of these two would give
up and they would fight until one of
them was dead
you know that would be a Simple Thing
Ronan because of the way he's his whole
life was about just battling and teal
the same he just it would come and would
come down to one moment and it would go
either way and it would come down to
look
I mean what was that one uh the the one
seen as like I guess we're walking and
breaks up them actually fighting on
Atlantis was they've been going at this
for what four hours or eight hours
whatever it was it's like either one was
gonna stop anytime soon oh it's gonna be
double triple that time so
one just let up yeah I like actually I
like to do the cons I do there close
quarter combat teal could win in a
hunting situation where both parties
armed
Ronan would win but that's in the
different scenarios I'm thinking just a
straight
boom and and yeah yeah I wouldn't even
guarantee tilk in close quarters just
yeah because of the SGA scene
they fought they kicked each other's ass
next statement zelanka was the smartest
character in all of Stargate
no but close
no
you actually look at his storyline the
amount of times Rodney started the
progress process and zelenka came in and
actually solved it
I think he's very intelligent I do think
him and McKay are probably on par
in a lot of ways but McKay is just that
slightly bit above him I think what she
had watched sdu more recently because I
feel like Rush might actually be the
smartest one out of all of them
just from where you guys have been
dealing well if you're gonna argue that
you have to actually say the Eli was
smarter because for the basically a dog
he does a lot in points I said I wish
I'd watch this to you a lot more
recently than I have so I'm just kind of
going off our conversation the last 56
minutes
well last episode of Stargate Atlantis
who saved the day oh that's true
okay I I would argue that zelinka may
very well be the smartest character or
literally on par with Sam Rush Rodney
Eli
but where he lacks is his creativity all
the others literally know how to like
put put bad situations and turn them
good where zelink is more like buy the
books and he's just like he gets
overwhelmed quickly and has to be told
what to do sometimes and besides that
he's freaking genius uh let's sprinkle
these little things and I think him I
think Rodney's more creative than zelink
or even though
had had a little bit more creatively he
probably could be smarter I agree with
Harris there
well this could work so let's try it and
then he just makes it work
the bit where the puddle jumper got
stuck in the gate
remember that episode and Rodney and it
was the link that came to do all the
procedure stuff in like step by step by
step by step and he as the link is saved
the day
but it was it was by the book like you
said it was it was math
yeah maths however you want to put it so
yeah
he's not he's one of those things isn't
it that how do you do that anyway how
would you argue that Rodney's not
smarter than Sam Sam created that you
know got this target working you know
it's like oh
it's it's a difficult the question was
is the length of the smartest character
in Stargate the answer to that is no
because you've got characters like Janus
and Merlin they were way smarter
yeah
okay the smartest human in
well you could argue that the Ancients
are humans because we are the second
evolution of the Ancients
I I think it goes right though in the
comment section all math boys gonna get
it at the end of the day
because we literally put everybody like
we put zelinka if we're saying oh he's
the smartest character who do we put him
on par with Russian Rodney and maybe Sam
but then again who's smarter than them
more creative smart yeah
it's definitely I think definitely has
the potential to be the smartest but he
doesn't quite understand everything to
be the smartest yet well it comes down
once he learns it and he's like
proficient he will literally be the the
most intelligent person within Stargate
I reckon yeah well it comes really it
comes down to how you want to Define
smart in this case is it just pure
intelligence is it
Common Sense slash wisdom some kind of
combination of both because wisdom
allows for the creativity that you get
with Sam and Rodney and whatever but you
know like the straight art this just if
it came down to straight IQ
you know
it could be zelinka or whatever the name
is but uh you know it's it basically
comes down to uh
is it an out of the box situation or
will straight line thinking solve it
um
and if it's an out of a box situation
you want Sam or uh Rodney
what have you if you want if you if you
straight line Solutions the link is
perfect for that Russia can handle that
so really it's situational really when
it comes down to
nobody's mentioned Dr Bill Lee
who cares so um sorry you could have
said any name then and I would have said
who cares I'm sorry
it was funnier than it was Bill Lee that
she was edited on
Falcon made the Avenger virus
yeah yeah I I like the comment we said
O'Neill when she had this stuff
downloaded and underneath the the Asgard
lived in you right we've smashed through
the last couple Jonas good call Bob I
forgot about Jonas
I think that these characters are as
intelligent as they need to be to make
the story
happening I mean yeah
so the Rodney and Shepherd Bromance was
better more interesting and funnier than
the O'Neill and Daniel bromance
yes yeah 100 agreement
there's literally almost as much of it
as O'Neill and Jack because Jack leaves
and and Daniel leaves at a certain point
too yeah twice yeah Daniel and O'Neil's
story from the movie that you know their
evolution to the that then they have
like that little Bromance that Bromance
at the end
um it changed in SG one it started off
with it but then teal came into it until
colonial's relationship
was very different again but it by the
end of it changed and at times they were
like brothers that were just or dad and
a son maybe they were just it felt like
they just irritated each other more than
anything else towards the end I feel
like the Jack and Daniel Dynamic was
in the beginning father and son
um
and then it slowly became
more brotherly like especially when when
Daniel ascended and they came to visit
Jack that was very impossibly
he's going visit your brother if he was
in prison kind of thing
there's lovely in later ones when uh
when Daniel died again and Jack was like
well he's not dead he'll be here in a
minute
to believe he was dead
um
with
um what's his name Shepard and McKay I
think it was always brotherly yeah with
them they did annoy each other yeah
Brothers but they
they bounced off each other and they
loved each other you could tell they
loved each other yeah there is McKay
respected Shepard Shepard as much as he
didn't want to admit it respect McKay
and it worked
mm-hmm well I don't think that that that
that kind of dynamic wasn't really
present with Jack and Daniel because
they would they both just worked anyway
they both worked as a team it was a
professional relationship
they didn't have to like earn the trust
of each other they already did that in
the movie kind of thing so we never saw
the build up in sg1 because it already
happened but we kind of see it more in
SGA
yeah okay
what do you think huh
I think the I think Matt pretty much
covered it like I don't there's not
really a lot I can add to that like
I think that because then Matt will
start thinking that his opinions matter
more than the rest of us and
um and let's be honest he already thinks
a little bit that's why I keep having to
tell him to shut up
I've told you to shut up today so you
you can get a free one it's fine
um last one then and then we'll call it
a day
sg1 is the greatest Sci-Fi show ever
made
discuss now Futurama
thank you
no it definitely is it definitely is the
greatest firefighter of all time not not
Futurama sorry Harris that was a joke
what's your armor isn't even the
greatest sci-fi cartoon ever made that's
the Jetsons
sci-fi
The Jetsons they just have ships in the
background they're not that they do do
some sci-fi things but it's more
it's just Flintstones in space
but as it goes
oh yeah
a Futurama it literally goes so deep is
not even funny you gotta go watch a
couple I know it does sometimes they
have the best depiction of what what we
should or could consider God from a
human perspective I think anybody's ever
done and they definitely make some good
jokes out of it too which is great but
they're wonderful just have a look check
out some of the things as soon as I said
that Sue yes
Jones yes Kerry agreed oh yes Dave oh
God no
no Jersey original Star Trek real Star
Trek is the most groundbreaking
[Music]
um
to a point socially I don't know what
that means so
um
the expansion might be
it might be my pick honestly
okay all right it's not one pick for the
greatest I love it but it's not a great
flip for my picks like it's always going
to be started but what does greatest
mean
what is what has touched your heart and
touched your downstairs area and made
you feel like
I made you feel
the Mass Effect video games right there
I'm waiting for those shows okay
it looks cool as well the mass effects
what did that dude say what was that
right oops I've got to remove that so
okay
I missed it oh
I I saw it no idea I have no idea what
that means but he kept repeating it so
he's on timeout
he's fantastic yeah you're entertainment
you get a very naughty boy yeah
I've only had to put one person in
timeout ever but like I keep running
into them on other streams because he
moves in the same kind of YouTube
circles I do and like any time I show up
he dips he's this happened in December
like my third or fourth stream period
and dude is still butt hurt about it
it's actually kind of funny yeah I've
I've got a nemesis who follows me around
and keeps changing his name on YouTube
and then reappears and he'll start to
try to have like possible probable
conversations with me and then every so
often he'll say something I'm like I
know who you are you just bloody hell
stop it
then it gets nasty about it and starts
getting really aggressive and then he
starts having to go other people on the
decision you have to you have to remove
him eventually it's not I don't want to
do it I don't agree with censorship I
think but when you're starting to go
over people you're gone is this the yeah
five four six two no it's not even yeah
he started off as ham fan of this guy
and then he keeps changing his name
oh he then because he kind of got me
said look but if you carry on I'm gonna
block you if anything started
threatening me if you block me I'm gonna
get all my mates to come after you and
we're gonna do I'll I'll flood your
comments with things you can't block me
like things
[Laughter]
for like months now I'm like give me
hate Watchers engagement
we've got a few hate watches we've got a
few people that think we're full of [__]
we make everything up we talk about and
I think and they'll just come every so I
think John put a video ah you got that
wrong
Mike zero or Doom [__] never think that
no
I don't even know who those people are
yeah I was like Jay doesn't know who
those people are he just threw them off
I'm sure there's a nope you've got
you've got over 20 000 subscribers
there's gonna be a few people here
though they'll be like yes yeah I know
there'll be a few people there are two
they're two of the biggest
Star Wars scoopers out there but really
all their channels is clickbait throwing
stuff against the wall and occasionally
it sticks and they're like oh see I was
right like yeah but what about people
say about last 25 videos
they have said that about us okay
some of it will be true if you if you
search
I'm not suggesting do this but just
search I I did it I searched sidetracked
on Reddit
just in the comments and it's always in
the Stargate subreddit and it's
literally that oh they that they just
they just say things and wait for it to
stick like but literally and they caught
they called they called us like
the exact phrasing was but one of them
called it's like the the bozos or the
idiots from the North or something was
like I'm not even from the north you two
are American
yeah
it was stormy so you still had two
Americans but the things I think with
some of these people they just you just
annoying more when you then are proven
right
you know I mean it's just like Jenny
stiven goes on dialogue and she
mentioned us every other bloody word for
an hour Sidetrack when I said this or
the rose
and then they're going just finally
somebody's actually but I think when you
get it right they're just annoys him
even more yeah should we post that video
on your channel be like uh if you think
we're full of crap reference this I'm
not too far away I don't get it that
much though and there's some people that
are going to be if you've got a YouTube
channel and say right I've got I've
spoken to somebody that works in this
because of those people like you
mentioned and other people and football
is the same thing there's people go on
and pretending I've got somebody in the
know
um and they're just they're bullshitting
but at the end of the day if you
consistently
makes sense and is right and you don't
clickbait which we don't much with a
little bit because you still have to
feed the elgo the algo runs on click
yeah you want people to watch the video
Don't you so you do it a little bit you
tease them a little bit you can but I've
I'm quite I don't like I don't like
doing things like on videos where they
go and you must watch this video and
then while you're watching this video
and then in five or ten minutes when
we've actually tell you the thing that
we're going to tell you about but other
meantime look at this thing over here
and then they go on and on and on and
like nine minutes into the video they
finally say this thing that actually
think that's not I knew that I hate that
so I don't do that
they're lovely guys they are lovely guys
but I don't like the way they do that
part of the videos oh their videos are
much better than us don't get me wrong
much better than us but that bit of
annoys me and they don't they're not the
only ones to do it loads of people do it
um I love their voiceovers
yeah they are they are really good the
guy has just got a voice for voiceovers
yeah
he has got a really cool voice actually
so he's a nice guy as well they are
really nice guys
um what was the question oh yeah is
Target for me back to the question
I'm gonna be the professional and draw
this back here this time
um
[Laughter]
like I haven't obviously I have not seen
all the Sci-Fi
um so for me of the Sci-Fi I have seen
it is it's it's my personal greatest
Sci-Fi show until I watch something
different and maybe that one hits me
harder I don't know but at this point in
my existence yes stargate's the best
sci-fi I personally have ever seen
and I think that's fine and at the end
of the day it's my sci-fi that's that's
the thing it's my show it's it's the one
it's like if I was if this was football
Stargate is my man united
I respect other teams but Stargate sg1
will always be that stuff it's way
better than Man United
[Laughter]
there it is I was waiting for that yeah
I was like okay one Manchester beat the
other one so are you happy or sad right
now and I'm gonna assume since you
didn't respond it was sad because City
one and you're yeah I think I think I
did respond and I didn't just one saying
I'm very sad so yeah I don't know I was
getting a bit drunk by that point
because of sad and yes man you lost Sue
they did you're becoming a bit used to
it I can't I can't remember a single
time the members of Stargate lost
Sam lost
um anneal
and several other boyfriends
like like nine
yeah they had that stuff yeah
every time it mattered so they're like
Champions League they've always won
um
their World Cup they've always won their
whatever the
best
I don't I don't follow football but
okay
they might not win every game but they
win the league in the end that's what
you're saying yeah all right guys thank
you so so much we are doing that to all
of my statements I I think we had a
bloody marvelous chat there
um even better than I was hoping bloody
more of an excuse oh yes well how scared
Jamie was at the 50 minute Mark he's
like I still have half of these
questions
he was like we're about to go two hours
if stormy was here this is when he'd say
something fascinating that we'd then be
stuck here for the next 45 minutes so
first
it's not in the bag have you guys gone
to see that yet though seriously have
you guys
which one I know you have these two have
you guys going to see across the spider
verse yet I've not even seen the first
one
Mr wearing a marble hat come on
oh and Jay I just don't have anything to
call you out on right now but
yeah and you think Futurama's the best
sci-fi ever made I I wear this hat
because it fits my massive head
earlier you were messing with your
lights and you didn't have a hat on and
I was looking away because I tried to
look at the camera and then when I
looked down you had a freaking hat on I
want to go well what happened to the Hat
we're more professional than that aren't
we
guys we're gonna call it a day so thank
you so so much everyone in the comments
you've been amazing today as always
you've been absolutely smashing it um
I'll have to go back through and read
them all later because I can't read and
talk it's a nuisance
um signed the petition yeah it's in the
comments to get Brad Wright involved for
Stargate I think we literally have a
couple of weeks that if we're going to
influence anything we've got maybe like
two weeks these decisions are getting
made
um if anything we know that they'd start
to actually talk to people at MGM about
maybe putting a team together so
it's happening
um I should say actually that the one
thing
um
I will speak to somebody last week this
is Amazon seemed to be trying to do a
big deal with the studio either Warner
Brothers but they think it's Sony oh
another one and it says he thinks that
that's tied to Stargate he thinks
they're trying to do this big
multi-movie deal with a with something
and that's what's holding things up
um in that video the other day when
you're talking about this it was Sony
that's already worked well with penguin
in a Parker right yeah they're doing um
God of War together okay yeah so yes
I'm being put in a position where I'm
forced to root for Sony they've been
involved in Stargate before as well
they both produced two seasons of SGU
SGA sorry I think I didn't know that um
so they have been involved with Stargate
before so
evidently they've forgotten how to do
live action since then hopefully someone
can remind them I think they've got
decent things I mean like you look as
things like the boys Sony
but what we look what they're looking at
is just basically Studio space Sony owns
the business there won't be an awful lot
more than that and they've got the GI
okay
right it's just going to be the Sony
play pen for everyone to play in yes
basically they were also uh the
production company for Atlanta season
two
they've actually got a decent connection
with them with style getting them so
yeah I I think I if I was going to put
money on it right now and I don't know
anything that I haven't told you guys on
this matter but unfortunately there are
certain things like I find out that I
can't tell you I'm not allowed on this
case I know nothing nobody seems to know
other than that Amazon are working
towards a big deal with somebody but
they're keeping it very close to their
chest because they've got to because
this deal when it's Nest is worth
a lot of money well yeah hundreds of
millions of dollars
um so it's going to be kept close to the
chest
um but in this case we don't know who
that is but if I was going to bet on it
I'd say it was Sony
I'd I'd be actually almost surprised if
it wasn't because of the Penguin and the
Parker connection because Stargate
connection but also because Amazon have
been working really closely with Sony
for a while MGM we're closer to Warner
Brothers
um Hannah have been for a while
Amazon are closer to Sony
so it's almost like they they would pick
Sony just to put their marker just to
say well you would have picked Warner
Brothers to begin with when you were MGM
on your own but now you're with us we're
going with Sony yeah but also I think I
think if they do this big deal
where basically Amazon will basically go
and with Sony right this these Studios
these seven eight Studios for the next
10 years
you're just doing Amazon projects that's
that that's the there's a hundreds of
millions of dollars of investment
billions of dollars of investment into
Sony and they Sony will partner with
Amazon for the next decade that's the
sort of thing they're looking at that's
the sort of deal we're talking about
um and it will be it will be
groundbreaking if they may if they make
that deal
um and that's what I'm being told Amazon
would like to do with somebody
they want consistency for the next
decade it's a big payday whoever gets it
with somebody though does that mean it
has to be Sony because they're also
teaming up with Microsoft for like the
Fallout TV series right now and if that
goes well
but Microsoft don't have Studios again
that's money and Microsoft own the IP
don't they so they've got to deal with
them
[Music]
Microsoft just for licensing
okay yeah that makes sense okay
um Apple uh Apple have basically done
this deal with Warner Brothers already
Apple have got a really strong
connection with Warner Brothers and
they've got multiple videos open
activities
um Apple have very much put their stock
in Waterbury that's that's their deal
Amazon thing but it's going to be much
bigger a much bigger deal because Amazon
are looking at cinematic movies TV
series everything and you know so let's
see what happens I I think if this is
going to happen it's gonna happen the
next six to six weeks two months let's
go
because
um everything's got to be nice things
like Robocop and stuff like this
it's not just Target we're talking about
the MGM have got to start making movies
Amazon have got to start taking
advantage of MGM now they've got to
they've got everything lined up the way
they want to they've now got to start
taking advantage of it because that's
eight billion dollars they spent however
hundreds of millions of dollars have
spent setting it right since
they've got to start doing something
with it now and they've done nothing yet
so
it's gonna yeah if they don't do it soon
we're not going to get to see Legally
Blonde three I mean yeah I was about to
say Legally Blonde three is probably the
thing that they've like
I don't know how we don't talk about
that every day I mean I I've been
wearing that for doing so many Stargate
videos that
so if we talk more legally blind three
and kind of get it pushed to fruition
quicker that means we can get back to
talking Stargate faster right and get it
out right
yeah maybe let's push it through and
then we'll start the campaign Harris for
Legally Blonde three oh you can be the
love interest
you don't have to ask me twice I play
the 20 years younger love interest any
day it's gonna be a workout regimen and
some good food I'm ready get help get in
shape come on
laughs
that does right guys thank you so much
we will see you next week
um live as usual at the same normal time
normal time and we won't be serious like
next week two hours earlier
two hours earlier than this week so um
back to normal time but thank you so so
much guys say say bye bye everybody
bye-bye see ya wait a second cause I'm
not ready wait a second okay I'm ready
bye
thank you
foreign